Voy a hablar con ustedes de tres de mis inventos
que pueden tener efectos sobre decenas de millones de personas,
lo cual esperamos ver que suceda.
En la película anterior comentamos algunas de las cosas que hicimos antes,
como los stents y las bombas de insulina para diabéticos.
Y me gustaría hablar muy brevemente sobre tres nuevos inventos
que cambiarán las vidas de mucha gente.
En la actualidad, toma en promedio tres horas
desde que el paciente reconoce los primeros síntomas de un ataque cardíaco,
hasta que ese paciente llega a una sala de emergencias.
Y a las personas con isquemia silente --
lo que en lenguaje simple significa que no tienen ningún síntoma --
les lleva aún más tiempo llegar al hospital.
El IAM, infarto agudo de miocardio,
que son palabras técnicas de médico para cobrarles más dinero --
(risas)
-- es un ataque al corazón. Incidencia anual: 1.2 millones de Estadounidenses.
Mortalidad: 300,000 personas mueren por año.
Cerca de la mitad, 600,000, quedan con daños permanentes al corazón
que les causarán problemas muy graves más tarde.
Así, 900,000 personas habrán muerto
o sufrirán daños significativos en los músculos del corazón.
Los pacientes suelen negar los síntomas, particularmente nosotros los hombres,
porque somos muy valientes. Somos muy valientes,
y no queremos admitir que estoy sintiendo un dolor del infierno en el pecho.
Entonces, aproximadamente 25% de todos los pacientes nunca tuvo síntomas.
¿Qué vamos a hacer con ellos? ¿Cómo podemos salvar sus vidas?
Esto es particularmente cierto de los diabéticos y mujeres ancianas.
Bien, ¿qué hace falta para el aviso más temprano posible de un ataque cardíaco?
¿Una forma de determinar si hay una obstrucción completa de una arteria coronaria?
Eso, señores y señoras, es un ataque al corazón.
El medio consiste en notar algo un poco técnico,
la elevación del segmento ST en el electrocardiograma.
En lenguaje simple, eso significa que
si hay una señal eléctrica en el corazón, y una parte del ECG --
a la que llamamos el segmento ST -- se eleva,
éso es un signo seguro de un ataque al corazón.
Y si ponemos una computadora en el cuerpo de una persona en riesgo,
podríamos saber, aún antes de que tenga síntomas,
que está teniendo un ataque al corazón, para salvar su vida.
Bien, el doctor puede programar un nivel de voltaje de esta elevación ST
que disparará una alarma de emergencia,
vibración como la de su celular, pero justo en su clavícula.
Y cuando hace bip, bip, bip, mejor que hagas algo con eso,
porque si quieres vivir tienes que buscar tratamiento médico.
Así que tenemos que probar estos dispositivos
porque la FDA simplemente no nos deja usarlos en personas
a menos que lo lo pongamos a prueba primero,
y el mejor modelo para esto parecen ser los cerdos.
Y lo que intentamos con el cerdo fueron electrodos externos en la piel,
como ven en una sala de emergencia,
y les voy a mostrar por qué no andan bien.
Y luego ponemos un electrodo, o sea un cable, en el ventrículo derecho dentro del corazón,
que hace el eletrocardiograma, o sea la señal de voltaje de adentro del corazón.
Bien, el cerdo, en la línea base,
antes de que bloqueáramos su arteria para simular un ataque cardíaco, esa era la señal.
Después de 43 segundos, aún un experto no notaba la diferencia,
y después de tres minutos -- bien,
si ustedes realmente lo estudiaron, verían una diferencia.
¿Pero qué sucedió cuando miramos dentro del corazón del cerdo, al electrocardiograma?
Esta era la línea base -- antes que nada, una señal mucho más grande y confiable.
Segundo, apostaría que aún ustedes que no están entrenados pueden ver la diferencia,
y vemos aquí una elevación del segmento ST justo después de esta línea puntiaguda.
Miren la diferencia aquí -- no es complicado,
cualquier persona sin experiencia podría ver esa diferencia,
y se pueden programar computadoras para detectarla fácilmente.
Luego, miren eso después de tres minutos.
Vemos que la señal que está realmente en el corazón,
podemos usarla para decirle a la gente que están teniendo un ataque cardíaco
aún antes de que tengan síntomas así podemos salvar sus vidas.
Luego lo probamos con mi hijo, el Dr. Tim Fischell,
lo probamos con algunos pacientes humanos que tenían un stent colocado.
Bien, él dejó el globo inflado para bloquear la arteria,
para simular una obstrucción, eso es un ataque cardíaco.
Y no es difícil ver que la línea base
es la primera imagen arriba a la izquierda.
Al lado, a los 30 segundos, ven esta elevación aquí,
luego esta elevación -- esta es la elevación ST.
Y si tenemos una computadora que pueda detectarlo,
podemos decirle que está teniendo un ataque cardíaco tan temprano
que puede salvar su vida y prevenir una Insuficiencia Cardiaca Congestiva.
Y luego lo hizo de nuevo. Llenamos el globo de nuevo unos minutos después
y aquí ven, aún después de 10 segundos, una gran elevación en este trozo,
por lo que podemos poner computadoras adentro, bajo su pecho como un marcapasos,
con un cable en su corazón como un marcapasos.
Y las computadoras no duermen.
Tenemos una pequeña batería y con esta pequeña batería
la computadora funcionará 5 años sin necesitar reemplazos.
¿Cómo se ve el sistema?
Bien, a la izquierda está el DMI, o sea dispositivo médico implantable,
y mañana en la carpa pueden verlo -- lo han exhibido.
Es más o menos de este tamaño, como un marcapasos.
Se implanta con técnicas muy convencionales.
Y el DEX es un dispositivo externo que pueden tener su la mesa de luz.
Los despertará y les dirá que muevan su rabo a la sala de emergencia.
cuando la cosa se apaga porque, si no lo hacen, están en un lío serio.
Y luego, finalmente, un programador ajustará el nivel de la estimulación,
que es el nivel que dice que están teniendo un ataque cardíaco.
La FDA dice, OK, prueben este dispositivo final en algún animal antes de construirlo
el cual decimos es un cerdo, así que tenemos que provocarle un ataque de corazón,
y cuando van a la granja, no es fácil provocar ataques al corazón a los cerdos,
así que dijimos, bien, somos expertos en stents.
Esta noche verán algunos de los stents que inventamos.
Dijimos, le pondremos un stent,
pero no vamos a ponerle un stent como el que ponemos a las personas,
vamos a ponerle un stent de cobre,
y este stent de cobre erosiona la arteria y causa ataques al corazón.
No es muy lindo, pero, después de todo, teníamos que encontrar la respuesta.
Así que tomamos dos stents de cobre y los pusimos en la arteria de este cerdo,
y déjenme mostrarles el resultado que es muy gratificante
en cuanto concierne a las personas que tengan enfermedades coronarias.
Ahí está, el jueves a la mañana detuvimos la medicación del cerdo
y ahí está su electro, la señal de adentro del corazón del cerdo
saliendo por radio telemetría.
Luego, el viernes a las 6:43, comenzó a tener ciertas señales,
que más tarde hicimos correr al cerdo alrededor --
No voy a entrar en esta etapa inicial.
Pero miren lo que sucedió a las 10:06 después de que quitamos la medicación al cerdo
que le evitaba un ataque cardíaco.
Cualquiera de ustedes ahora es un experto en elevación ST. ¿Pueden verla aquí?
¿Pueden verla en la imagen después del gran aumento del QRS, ven la elevación ST?
El cerdo a las 10:06 estaba teniendo un ataque cardíaco.
¿Qué sucede después de que usted tiene el ataque cardíaco, este bloqueo?
Su ritmo se vuelve irregular, y esto es lo que sucedió 45 minutos después.
Luego, fibrilación ventricular, el corazón tiembla en lugar de latir,
esto es justo antes de la muerte del cerdo, y luego el cerdo murió, se puso plano.
Pero tuvimos un poco más de una hora en que podríamos haber salvado la vida del cerdo.
Bien, debido a la FDA, no salvamos la vida del cerdo,
porque necesitamos hacer este tipo de investigación animal por los humanos.
Pero cuando se trata del bien de un humano, podemos salvar su vida.
Podemos salvar las vidas de personas que están en alto riesgo de ataque cardíaco.
¿Cuál es la respuesta al infarto agudo de miocardio, un ataque cardíaco, hoy?
Bien, ustedes sienten algún dolor de pecho o indigestión.
No está tan mal, deciden no hacer nada.
Pasan varias horas y se pone peor, y aún un hombre no lo ignoraría.
Finalmente, van a la sala de emergencias.
Esperan que traten a los quemados y a otros pacientes críticos,
porque el 75% de los pacientes que van a una sala de emergencia con dolor de pecho,
no tienen un IAM, así que no los toman muy en serio.
Finalmente los atienden. Toma más tiempo
tomar el electrocardiograma sobre su piel y diagnosticarlo,
y es difícil de hacer porque no tienen los datos de línea base,
que la computadora que les ponemos adentro tiene.
Finalmente, si tienen suerte, son tratados tres o cuatro horas después del incidente,
pero el músculo del corazón ha muerto.
Y éste es el tratamiento típico. En el mundo desarrollado. No en Africa --
este es el tratamiento típico en el mundo avanzado hoy.
Así que desarrollamos el AngelMed Guardian System
y ponemos un dispositivo dentro de este paciente, llamado el AngelMed Guardian implantado.
Y cuando ustedes tienen una obstrucción, la alarma suena
y envía la alarma y el electro a un dispositivo externo,
que tiene su electrocardograma basal de hace 24 horas
y el que causó la alarma, así que puede llevarlos a la sala de emergencias
y mostrarlos, y decir, atiéndanme ya.
Luego va a un centro de operaciones en red,
donde toman sus datos de su base de datos de pacientes
que pusieron en algún lugar central, digamos, en Estados Unidos.
Luego va a un centro de diagnóstico, y dentro de un minuto de su ataque cardíaco,
su señal aparece en la pantalla de una computadora
y la computadora analiza cuál es su problema.
Y la persona que está ahí, el practicante médico, lo llama --
esto también es un celular -- y dice,
"Sr. Smith, esté está en un lío feo, tiene un problema.
Hemos llamado a la ambulancia. La ambulancia está en camino.
Lo pasará a buscar, y luego vamos a llamar a su doctor y decirle sobre esto.
Vamos a enviarle la señal a él, lo que tenemos, que dice que usted tiene un ataque cardíaco,
y vamos a enviar la señal al hospital
y vamos a hacer que la analicen aquí,
y usted va a estar con su doctor
y lo cuidaremos para que usted no muera de un ataque al corazón".
Este es el primer invento que quería describir.
(aplausos)
Y ahora quisiera hablar de algo enteramente diferente.
Al principio yo no creía que los dolores de migraña fueran un problema grave
porque nunca había tenido una migraña,
pero luego hablé con algunas personas que tienen tres o cuatro cada semana de su vida
y sus vidas se arruinan completamente por ello.
En nuestra compañía tenemos una declaración de misión con respecto a la migraña, que es,
"Prevenir o mejorar los dolores de cabeza por migraña
mediante la aplicación de un pulso magnético seguro, controlado,
aplicado, en la medida de lo necesario, por el paciente".
Ahora, probablemente hay muy pocos físicos aquí.
Si usted es un físico usted sabe que hay una cierta Ley de Faraday,
que sice que si aplico un pulso magnético a agua salada --
de paso, eso es lo que son sus cerebros --
generará corrientes eléctricas, y la corriente eléctrica en el cerebro
puede borrar un dolor de cabeza por migraña.
Eso es lo que hemos descubierto.
Así que aquí hay una imagen de lo que estamos haciendo.
Los pacientes que tienen una migraña precedida por un aura
tienen una franja de neuronas excitadas -- que se muestran en rojo --
que se mueve de tres a cinco milímetros por minuto hacia el centro del cerebro.
Y cuando llega al centro del cerebro, es cuando el dolor de cabeza comienza.
Ahí está esta migraña que es precedida por un aura visual,
y este aura visual, de paso -- y les mostraré una imagen --
pero es como que siendo pequeña, con pequeñas luces danzantes,
se hace mayor y mayor hasta que llena todo su campo visual.
Y lo que hemos probado es esto, aquí está un dispositivo llamado el Cadwell Model MES10.
Pesa unos 32 kg, tiene un cable de cerca de una pulgada de diámetro.
Y aquí está uno de los pacientes que tiene un aura
y siempre tiene un dolor de cabeza, uno malo, después del aura. ¿Qué hacemos?
Así es como se ve un aura.
Is una especie de luces danzantes divertidas, se ven aquí en el lado izquierdo y el derecho.
Y esto es un aura visual completa, como vemos arriba.
En el medio, nuestro experimentador, el neurólogo, que dijo,
"Voy a bajar esto un poco y voy a borrar la mitad de su aura".
Y, por Dios, el neurólogo la borró, y esto está en la imagen del centro,
la mitad del aura borrada por un corto pulso magnético.
¿Qué significa eso?
Eso significa que el pulso magnético está generando una corriente eléctrica
que está interfiriendo con la actividad eléctrica errónea en el cerebro.
Y finalmente él dice, "Ok, ahora voy a -- "
toda el aura se borra con un pulso magnético ubicado apropiadamente.
¿Cuál es el resultado? Diseñamos un despolarizador magnético,
que se ve así, que usted puede tener -- una dama, en su bolso,
y cuando usted tiene un aura puede probarlo y ver cómo funciona.
Bien, lo siguiente que tienen para mostrar es lo que salió en ABC News,
en Canal 7, la semana pasada en New York City, en las noticias de las 11.
Presentador: Para todos los que sufren dolores de migraña --
y hay 30 millones de estadounidenses así -- una posible respuesta esta noche.
La reportera de noticias testigo Stacy Sager esta noche, con una máquina pequeña y portátil
que literalmente borra sus migrañas.
Christina Sidebottom: Bien, mi primera reacción fue que esto era --
se veía terriblemente como un arma, y era muy extraño.
Stacy Sager: pero para Christina Sidebottom, valía la pena probar casi todo
si podía detener una migraña.
Puede verse tonto o aún amenazante cuando camina con esto en su cartera,
pero investigadores aquí en Ohio organizando pruebas clínicas para este supresor de migrañas,
dicen que está fundamentado científicamente.
Que, de hecho, cuando la persona media tiene una migraña,
es causada por algo similar a un impulso eléctrico.
El supresor crea un campo magnético para cotrarrestar eso.
Yousef Mohammed: en otras palabras, estamos tratando la electricidad con electricidad,
en lugar de tratar a electricidad con los químicos que usamos hoy en día.
SS: ¿Pero es seguro para usarlo todos los días?
Los expertos dicen que se ha estado investigando por más de una década,
y es necesario hacer más estudios de largo plazo. Christina ahora tiene mucha confianza en esto.
CS: ha sido lo más maravilloso para mi migraña.
SS: Los investigadores esperan presentar sus estudios a la FDA este verano.
Robert Fischell: Y ése es el invento para tratar las migrañas.
(Aplausos)
Ya ven, el problema es, 30 millones de estadounidenses tienen dolores de migraña,
y necesitamos una forma de tratarlo, y creo que ahora la tenemos.
Y este es el primer dispositivo que hicimos, y voy a hablar de mi segundo deseo,
que tiene algo que ver con esto.
Nuestras conclusiones de los estudios hasta ahora, en tres centros de investigación,
es que hay una mejora marcada en los niveles de dolor después de usarlo sólo una vez.
Los dolores de cabeza más severos respondieron mejor después de que lo hicimos varias veces,
y el descubrimiento inesperado indica que aún dolores de cabeza establecidos,
no sólo esos con aura, se tratan y disminuyen.
Y las auras pueden borrarse y la migraña, entonces, no pasa.
Y ése es el invento para la migraña del que estamos hablando y sobre el que estamos trabajando.
(Aplausos)
El tercer y último invento comenzó con una idea.
La epilepsia puede ser tratada mejor con estimulación eléctrica sensible.
Ahora, ¿por qué usamos -- agregamos, casi, un foco epiléptico?
Ahora, desafortunadamente, nosotros los técnicos, a diferencia del Sr. Bono,
tenemos que meternos con todas estas palabras técnicas.
Buen, la estimulación eléctrica sensible significa
que sensamos, en un lugar en su cerebro llamado foco epiléptico,
que es donde la epilepsia -- donde el ataque epiléptico comienza.
Sensamos ahí, que está por suceder,
y luego respondemos aplicando una energía eléctrica en ese punto,
que borra la señal errante
de modo que no tiene las manifestaciones clínicas de la migraña.
Usamos tecnología actual de marcapasos desfibrilador que se usa para el corazón.
Pensamos que podíamos adaptarlo para el cerebro.
El dispositivo podría implantarse bajo el cuero cabelludo
para que esté totalmente oculto y para evitar rotura de cables,
lo que pasa si lo pone en el pecho y trata de girar mucho su cuello.
Formamos una compañía para producir un neuro-marcapasos para la epilepsia,
como también para otras enfermedades del cerebro, porque todos los males del cerebro
son el resultado de alguna falla eléctrica en él,
lo que causa muchos, si no todos, los desórdenes cerebrales.
Formamos una compañía llamada NeuroPace
y comenzamos a trabajar en neuro-estimulación sensible,
y ésta es una imagen de cómo se ve el dispositivo,
que se pone en el hueso craneal.
Esta imagen probablemente es mejor.
Aquí tenemos nuestro dispositivo el cual ponemos en un marco.
Se hace un corte en el cuero cabelludo, se abre, el neurocirujano tiene una plantilla,
la marca, y usa una fresa de dentista
para quitar una parte del hueso craneal exactamente del tamaño de nuestro dispositivo.
Y esta noche, ustedes podrán ver el dispositivo en la carpa.
Y luego tenemos -- con cuatro tornillos, ponemos un marco,
luego insertamos el dispositivo y metemos los cables --
el que se ve en verde irá en la superficie del cerebro con electrodos,
al foco epiléptico, el origen de la epilepsia,
donde podemos sensar la señal eléctrica
y realizar un análisis por computadora que nos dice cuándo golpearlo con una corriente eléctrica
para prevenir la manifestación clínica del ataque.
El el cable azul, vemos lo que se llama un electrodo cerebral profundo.
Si esa es la fuente de la epilepsia, podemos atacarla también.
La solución completa: éste es el dispositivo,
es de 25 a 50 cm aproximadamente y, por raro que parezca,
justo el espesor de la mayoría de los huesos craneanos.
Las ventajas de la neuroestimulación sensitiva:
puede detectar y terminar los ataques antes de que ocurran los síntmas clínicos,
provee estimulación sólo cuando es necesario,
puede apagarse si el ataque desaparece, tiene efectos colaterales mínimos --
de hecho, en nuestras pruebas clínicas a la fecha,
no hemos visto efectos laterales en lo aproximadamente 40 pacientes a los que se implantó --
y es invisible, oculto cosméticamente,
así que si usted tiene epilepsia y tiene el dispositivo,
nadie lo sabrá porque no se ve que esté allí.
Y esto muestra un electroencefalograma,
y a la izquierda está la señal de un ataque espontáneo en uno de los pacientes.
Luego lo estimulamos, y ven cómo esa línea negra gruesa
y luego ven la señal del electroencefalograma volviendo a normal,
lo que significa que no tuvo la convulsión epiléptica.
Eso concluye mi discusión sobre epilepsia y --
el tercer invento que quiero discutir aquí esta tarde.
(aplausos)
Tengo tres deseos. Bien, no puedo hacer mucho por Africa.
Soy un técnico, trabajo en aparatos médicos,
que mayormente son cosas de alta tecnología como dijo el Sr. Bono.
El primer deseo es usar el neuroestimulador sensible a la epilepsia,
llamado RNS, por "responsive neuroestimulator" -- esa es una sigla brillante --
para el tratamiento de otros problemas del cerebro.
Bien, si vamos a usarlo para la epilepsia, ¿por qué diablos no probarlo con algo más?
Luego, ¿vieron cómo se veía ese dispositivo,
que la mujer usaba para curar sus migrañas?
Les digo esto: eso es algo que algunos ingenieros investigadores como yo armaríamos,
no lo que haría un verdadero diseñador de buenos equipos.
(risas)
Queremos que algunas personas, que realmente saben cómo hacerlo,
hagan estudios de ingeniería ergonómica y desarrollen el diseño óptimo
para el dispositivo portátil para tratar los dolores de la migraña.
Y algunos de los patrocinadores de esta reunión de TED son organizaciones así.
Entonces vamos a desafiar a los asistentes a TED
para que encuentren una forma de mejorar la asistencia sanitaria en EEUU,
donde tenemos problemas que Africa no tiene.
Y reduciendo los juicios por mala praxis --
los juicios por mala praxis no son un problema africano, son un problema de EEUU.
(aplausos)
Entonces, para ir rápido a mi primer deseo --
el cerebro opera con señales eléctricas.
Si las señales eléctricas crean un trastorno en el cerebro,
la estimulación eléctrica puede vencer ese trastorno actuando sobre las neuronas del cerebro.
In otras palabras, si arman lío con las señales eléctricas,
quizás, poniendo otras señales eléctricas de una computadora en el cerebro,
podemos contrarrestar eso.
Una señal en el cerebro que dispara una disfunción cerebral
podría sensarse como disparador para la electroestimulación
como estamos haciendo con la epilepsia.
Pero aún si no hay señal,
la electroestimulación de una parte apropiada del cerebro puede apagar un trastorno cerebral.
Y consideren el tratamiento de trastornos sicóticos --
y quiero que con esto se involucre el grupo TED --
como el trastorno obsesivo-compulsivo
que, actualmente, no se trata bien con drogas, y afecta a cinco millones de estadounidenses.
Y el Sr. Fischer, y su grupo de NeuroPace, y yo mismo creo
que podemos causar un mejora dramática en el TOC en EEUU y el mundo.
Ese es el primer deseo.
(aplausos)
El segundo deseo es, en este momento,
las pruebas clínicas de estimuladores magnéticos transcraneanos --
eso significa TMS, el aparato para tratar dolores de migraña --
parecen bastante existosas.
Bien, esta es la buena noticia.
El dispositivo portátil actual está lejos de un diseño óptimo,
tanto en lo ergonómico como en apariencia.
Creo que ella dijo que parecía un arma. A muchísima gente no le gustan las armas.
(risas)
Involucrar una compañía que haya tenido éxito previo
en ingeniería de factores humanos y diseño industrial
para oprimizar el diseño del primer aparato de TMS portátil
que se venderá a los pacientes con dolores de cabeza de migraña.
Y ese es el segundo deseo.
(aplausos)
Y, de los 100,000 dólares de premio, que TED fue tan generoso de darme,
estoy donando 50,000 dólares a la gente de NeuroPace
para avanzar con el tratamiento de TOC, trastorno obsesivo-compulsivo,
y estoy ofreciendo otros 50,000 a una compañía
para optimizar el diseño del aparato para migrañas.
Y así voy a usar mis 100,000 dólares de premio.
(aplausos)
Bien, el tercer y último deseo es algo --
desafortunadamente, es mucho más complicado porque implica abogados.
(risas)
Bien, los juicios por mala praxis médica en EEUU
han aumentado el costo del seguro de mala praxis,
así que médicos competentes están dejando la práctica.
Los abogados toman casos en contingencia con la esperanza de una parte grande
de un monto grande otorgado por un jurado comprensivo, porque su paciente realmente terminó mal.
El alto costo de la salud en EEUU es parcialmente debido a los costos de juicios y seguros.
He visto imágenes, gráficos, en el USA Today de hoy
mostrando cómo escalan fuera de control, y este es un factor.
Bien, ¿cómo puede la comunidad de TED ayudar con esta situación?
Tengo un par de ideas para comenzar.
Y como punto inicial para discutir con el grupo TED,
una parte principal del problema es la naturaleza del alcance escrito
del consentimiento informado que el paciente o su esposa debe leer y firmar.
Por ejemplo, le pregunté a la gente con epilepsia
qué están usando para consentimiento informado.
¿Me creerían, 12 páginas, a espacio simple,
que el paciente tiene que leer antes de participar en nuestra prueba para curar su epilepsia?
¿Qué piensan que alguien logra luego de leer 12 páginas a espacio simple?
No entiende de qué diablos se trata.
(risas)
Este es el sistema actual. ¿Por qué no hacer un video?
Tenemos gente del espectáculo aquí,
tenemos gente que sabe cómo hacer videos,
con presentación visual de la anatomía y procedimientos mediante animación.
Todos saben que podemos hacerlo mejor con algo visual
que puede ser interactivo con el paciente, donde ven el video
y se los filma y apretan, ¿entiende esto? No, no entiendo.
Bien, entonces vamos con una explicación más simple.
Entonces hay una más simple y, oh sí, entiendo eso.
Bien, apriete el botón y está registrado, entendió.
Y esa es una de las ideas.
Ahora, también un video se hace con el paciente o esposa y un presentador médico,
con el paciente acordando que comprendió el procedimiento a hacer,
incluyendo todos los modos de falla posibles.
El paciente o esposa acuerdan no hacer un juicio
si ocurre una de las fallas de procedimiento.
Ahora, en EEUU, de hecho, no puede ceder su derecho de recurrir a juicio de jurados.
De todos modos, si el video está mostrando que se le explicó todo,
y está todo en el archivo en video,
es mucho menos probable que algún abogado gordo
tome este caso en contingencia, porque no será ni cerca tan buen caso.
Si ocurre un error médico, el paciente o esposa acuerdan en un juicio
por compensación justa por arbitraje en lugar de ir a la corte.
Esto salvaría cientos de millones de dólares en costos legales en EEUU
y disminuiría el costo de la medicina para todos.
Estos son sólo algunos puntos iniciales.
Y, así, este es el último de mis deseos.
Quisiera que hubiera más deseos pero tres es lo que tengo y aquí están.
(aplausos)